[Music]
one thing that was very interesting to
me obviously
I worked in the forensic pathology
department at Sheffield at the
medico-legal Center and then I also
moved into epidemiology later on it
became of great interest to me when did
we start recording everybody's death
more or less and why did we start doing
it what do we do with that information
so when it comes to documenting death I
think we can say fairly definitively
that nobody has done it as well as the
Egyptians this one dude with great
pyramiding Dinky's he got his death
extremely documented in a kind of
project that would have taken decades to
build
unfortunately for literally everybody
else we don't know too much about the
people who built it the conditions under
which they built it or how they did so
let's say about a hundred thousand
people worked on this but we only know
about the one guy about Khufu and his
pyramid but it does open up this idea
that while we think about documenting
death now as something that obviously
happens you have a death certificate
this has just not always been the case
it just hasn't always been all that
important to our societies who dies and
why unless you were very very very rich
or had committed quite a lot of crime
this sort of starts to change in the
British Isles evil coroner system and
this is where I have to refer to my
notes
we have Alfred in about 871 or so having
something that is called a coroner but
we don't really know from the historical
records what that coroner was charged to
do but medieval coroner's fully come in
with a kind of Norman administration in
the eleven 70s when we think about a
coroner now we think about the person
who determines the manner of death that
is how it's used in England and Wales
now so the the pathologist or doctor may
give you the cause of death
put your dick in a toaster and
electrocuted yourself and the manner of
death sorry couldn't help it
the manner of death misadventure that's
the coroner's job to determine if a
crime was committed back in medieval
times however they're really much more
of a glorified tax collector and what
that means is that if somebody dies and
their body was unclaimed and you run
across it you must raise the human cry
and the reason why you do this is
because the government wants to collect
any bits that the dead person might have
laid on the floor or if a crime was
committed they'd like to claim the
dagger that killed you and sell it on to
raise taxes so to give an example and
this is a completely this was not a real
person although I should point out you
can't libel the dead so let's say you
know Henri de Buckingham Clarke died of
a stab wound value of knives one
shilling 1327 and if any of you are on
Twitter there's an account called
medieval despot that just basically
tweets things like this automatically
and if you're wondering quite a lot of
things quite a lot of people get called
Clarke simply because it's anybody whose
profession involves writing including
students so you're thinking to yourself
like why is somebody who works at the
7-eleven going around and stabbing so
many people it's actually because the
word had a much broader meaning Xin
still at the same time we're only
recording certain types of deaths for
certain reasons this kind of also falls
out of use as the role of the coroner
starts to change the one that people
know about and the one that's really
much more directly related to how we
document death now are the Bills of
mortality the first ones are in 1592 and
obviously we know what's going on around
that time a whole lot of people are
dying really quickly because they're
sticking their dicks and toasters aka
plagues flags are happening and when a
plague is active let's say it's
summertime and the plaguing is easy
everybody in the city is dying a bill of
mortality will be issued and it lists by
parish how many people died so in the
city of London and think there were
twenty seven parishes within the city
walls and like twelve outside or
something like that and you know and you
have what were the other ones Middlesex
and Surrey sorry my London geography is
so poor the bit that Oxford start on the
bit the Cambridge started on for the
boat race so you have these occasional
little bulletins that come out telling
you how many people have died and where
they have died and the presumption being
they probably died of the plague
sometimes we also get their ages but we
don't get very much about who they are
exactly and when the plague season dies
down again we stop hearing about who's
dead you stop getting your little
notebook I don't know I've kind of got
to the age now that I'm in my forties I
actually do peruse various publications
looking for people I know who might be
dead and I I understand that this is
something that takes up quite a lot of
time as you get older looking for people
you know who might be dead so I like to
imagine somebody in this time kind of
flipping through and going ooh
15 people in such-and-such perished I'd
wonder if I know any of them more
importantly did I just like any of them
the Bills of mortality however start to
become a more permanent thing and when
they do this in 1603 the Worshipful come
for the worshipful company of parish
Clarke's people writing things down
start having a regular bill that they
are issuing with all the deaths and in
this because it isn't always Plague
season and they're doing it all the time
they start to record what people died of
so again we're not getting very much
detail on the individuals themselves
apart from age what killed them and
where they lived but names aren't really
attached to this in any way
in part because nobody's really
collecting taxes off the dead at this
point
this is where we start to get into an
inn
interesting kind of situation that
continues on until about 1836 and there
is an act that establishes the register
of births and deaths and this is the
progenitor of what we have today with
births marriages and deaths and now we
start to have names attached now we
start to have a bit more of biographical
detail and now everybody's got to be in
it everybody what this enables us to do
as scientists is epidemiology so this is
the diagram from John Snow
the 1854 cholera outbreak from the Broad
Street water pump at the time it was
thought that a lot of diseases the
theory of disease was known as the
miasma theory of disease we didn't
really have the infection theory of
disease yet people believed that
illnesses kind of came in bad air and
that if you were particularly delicate a
child or an older person you should stay
in at night so that the bad air didn't
get you people developed this more and
more so it's decaying organic matter
that brings you any host of diseases
what John Snow was able to do because he
had a lot of detail of who had died
where they had lived who they were was
go back to those places go knock on some
doors and go ask well what were these
people doing before they died where did
they go I want a detailed account of
what happened and that's how he was able
to connect the outbreak of cholera to
the specific water pumps that almost
everybody who died in this particular
outbreak had used this is where
epidemiology begins and the wonderful
thing about epidemiology in this country
is because we have such great
documentation going forward we can find
out quite a lot not just about who is
dying where and when they're dying and
the cause of their death but also what
causes the cause the etiology of disease
if we can start to put together factors
from people's life course we can start
to understand a little bit more what
might be the exposures
that lead to particular kinds of cancers
and that's the area that I worked in for
several years we knew that there were
thyroid cancers in the northeast of
England they were happening in
particular spots and we want to know
what is the exposure or set of exposures
the more information we have the better
this gets now the brilliant thing about
living in a country with the NHS is now
we have so much of that information on
databases there are data protection
measures in place to make sure that we
can't accidentally tell people you know
your particular medical history although
of course that does get broken from time
to time when you go to other countries
like the United States where I live now
though it's a completely different
picture there is not a national register
things are state-by-state not only are
things state-by-state some states do not
record these in any systematic way at
all so if I wanted to be in the state of
say Nevada and I wanted to look at
childhood thyroid cancers again I'm
starting from Ground Zero I would have
to go to different cancer hospitals and
start asking them for access to the data
to put it together the more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you